il est arrivé flanqué du maire de
belfort damien meslot et de l'ancien
maire jean pierre chevènement devant les
premiers salariés qui salue le président
de la république l'ancien ministre de
l'industrie s'invite dans la
conversation vous savez l'engagement des
bananes
pour devenir la rai plus pertinents
caramel arabe elle c'est le joyau
industriel de cette usine autrefois
alstom aujourd'hui general electric
demain bientôt edf emmanuel macron est
ici pour vanter le retour dans le giron
national de la turbine à vapeur la plus
puissante du monde qui équipe le parc
nucléaire français les que je voulais
vraiment vous dire aujourd'hui pour ma
part fait vous remercier parce que vous
avez porté à bout de bras ici
ce savoir faire fait compétences
au-delà de ce merci vous dire que vous
avez la confiance de la nation dans la
durée dans la durée car quelques minutes
plus tard à la tribune emmanuel macron
affiche les ambitions de la france en
matière nucléaire je souhaite que six
paires 2 soit construit et que nous
lancions les études sur la construction
de huit le pr2 additionnel autant de
nouvelles centrales dont les turbines
seront fabriqués à belfort un projet
économique et politique pour les
prochaines décennies